foreign
[Music]
s can feel constraining but remember the
point of this course is to learn how to
write clearly and persuasively think
about that think about the truth of your
argument
[Music]
you're an amazing personality I couldn't
ask for a more incredible daughter
are you actually trying to parent me
right now
who would want
part of their
you don't stay in touch with Mom she
really only tells me things about you
why
because that's all I want to know about
why'd you get all that weight someone
close to me passed away and it had an
effect on
me you haven't seen her since she was
eight years old and you're gonna
reconnect with her sorry I don't like
this this isn't a good idea I'm sorry
you say you're sorry one more time I
will stop at night right into you I
swear to God go ahead What's it gonna do
my internal organs are two feet in at
least
laughs
why do you suddenly need to see her so
bad why now
that person she is
I need to know it's just gonna have a
decent life where she cares about people
and it's just gonna be okay
I need to know that I have done one
thing right with my life
foreign
[Music]